did is at the center of nearly every
product your own your phone your TV even
have car products have become
increasingly customized to your needs
with the help of data allowing companies
like Netflix uber and Amazon to build
great data-driven products since every
product is data driven the melding of
data science and product management is
the future of product development data
project managers understand that
building products that incorporate data
requires a data strategy a plan for how
data will be collected transform and
analyze to unit keep position your
product to win in the market in Udacity
is data product manager nano degree
program you'll learn how to build
data-driven products backed by scalable
data strategies to deliver the right
experiences to the right users at the
right time in this nano degree program
you'll evaluate market data and create
visualizations to determine the key
matrices and features for a new product
you will integrate this data backed
evidence into a product proposal that is
supported by a scalable data pipeline
and warehousing strategy once you finish
you'll be able to create a data product
concept strategize a data pipeline and
storage infrastructure to support
scaling of the product and enhance the
product design based on user data
leverage data to build products that
position customers and businesses to
thrive enroll in Udacity data project
manager nano degree program today
[Music]